[Musique]
1-0 dumas raconte que porto ça va être
un appétit très solide il aurait pu
dévorer un mouton entier cuit à la
broche
par contre aramis avait le ballon plus
et si d'artagnan avec d'amener ses amis
mousquetaires son pays gasco maïté je
crois qu'il aurait dit pour army s'il
faut faire les fois les plus fins les x
reza et au sauternes
alors cela comme on les fait tout en
prenant fois comme celui ci en la salle
et on le poivre c'est déjà fait voilà on
le met dans une cale on le met marine et
pardon 24 heures avant d'en de sauternes
et le porto le même opération pour le
réservent en effet marine et 24 heures
avant dans le sauternes et de porto
après on sort de foi de la marinade
on le met dans la casserole à écrire et
vous t on le met dans la casserole bien
chaude et là en principe il va perdre de
la de gamme offrant beaucoup trop
n'arriva pas beaucoup promis mais voilà
on va bien le faire dorer de chaque côté
leur tournée voilà ils adorent et on va
le cerveau n'a de toute façon il va
finir de cuire
voilà voilà voilà riad aurait on a bien
la couleur et beaucoup de juges facile
en couleurs merveilleuses
on va est bien choisie ou marché on va
bien à déglacer avec le court terme
voilà la poule e m
il faut laisser réduire à cette sauce
bien réduire la sauce auvents tables qui
se alors pendant ce temps ont peut-être
commencé à préparer nos raisins parce
que les raisins ils ont mariné mais
après il faut les éplucher oh quelle
horreur il est aussi le salon c'est très
dur en affaires on épluche theresa on
prend la réserve c'est leur affaire mais
c'est comme ça et on va les chercher ces
petits pépins à cet effet à l'intérieur
en essayant de laisser leurs réserves
presse
après ce contact là ce n'est pas sale et
régine travail-là sirois aussi tout pour
l'instant notre petit jouet donc revenir
et d'huile réduire
il faut attendre qu'il y en a presque
plus oui il faut que ce soit une sauce
réduite
bon je vais les réserves
voilà dans le jus en effet doré un tout
petit peu mais il faut qu'ils restent
craquant quand même il faut pas que le
raisin soit mousse autres hormones y
voilà on va les laisser un tout petit
peu voilà c'est fait et nous allons
remettre notre foi voilà je regarde
comment ils sont là ils sont comme il
faut pas dire voilà et nous allons
remettre notre foi voilà nous allons
reposer notre foi et malheureux venant
couper mes tantes y voit là et nous
allons laisser finir de cuire tout
ensemble
alors là à peu près comme en adaptant on
peut pas dire il faut utiliser pour moi
il faut on veut pas dire la puissance ça
dépend de beaucoup de choses
il faut laisser réduire à une population
s'il faut n'y a pas de retard il faut
regarder cette eau et si je n'avais pas
sous la main du 26 terne et les résines
que pourrait faire le faux pogny alors
par exemple voilà la rompre en emploi
évidemment salez et poivrez
nous allons sortir le x 3,1 prendre la
poêle nous allons arriver le gaz voilà
on va attendre quelque chose tout petit
peu n'est ce pas là voilà
voilà la même opération que pour le foie
au sauternes
nous allons le faire dorer des deux
côtés on va tantôt plus faire ce temps
voilà bien comme les baux magnifique
superbe l'alto est quand même très
attentifs ont fait pas ce qu'il faut pas
aller trop vite on envoyait c'est pas un
peu trop fort on va baisser
voilà il va pas prendre en considération
ces deux magnifiques fois une qualité
supérieure
les restaurer
de retourner là et nous allons y mettre
les pommes que nous allons couper en
petits dés
mais à lavaur y mettaient dès maintenant
alors là non qu'ils se nomment tous non
on va déjà mettre quelques pôles de leur
faire des petites boulettes
il ya des petits appareils il sent très
bien que nous n'avons pas eu les nerfs
ça comme ça fait rien il faut il passer
à six leur général voilà et on va lier
de fondre associé avec de la compote
nous allons directement du porto en
annotant voilà l'une voire trois là nous
allons mettre de porto là non
la laisser réduire
évidemment un peu la sauce voilà ce un
bon ça sent bon ça sent bon voilà mais
nous allons leur tournée à nouveau voilà
regardez comme il est beau la voilà et
on va maintenant que la hausse est un
peu réduite
nous allons l'allier avec de la compote
la compote ce sera le fond de sauce
quand vous faites la compote vous
plaignez pas me vendre avant parce que
quelque part on n'appelle pas vous
plaindre non non non non non c'est pas
d'affaires s'est réduit et vous les
sucres est un peu dans les cuisines ou
pas trop un peu après un bris un peu
sucré une pointe de citron ouvriers tout
rien à qui remettre - non non non voilà
nous allons mettre la compote tout le
tour
et laisser mijoter voilà tout doucement
voilà vous avez laissé voir et pendant
combien de temps le double on ne peut
pas dire encore longue il faut voir il
faut surveiller au moins un quart
d'heure ah oui bon dans tout ça cuit
troisième recette du jour vous ai parlé
des fois où poivrer
pendant cet extra aussi alors qu'est ce
que vous faites pareil mais opération
c'est pas parce que c'est au poivre
qu'il faut pas saler poivrer
il faut saler poivrer aussi le poivre le
foie voilà toujours ça n'est pas vrai au
gros sel de bayonne au gros sel des voix
la part du sel de mer plutôt pourquoi
pas du sien de nerfs parce qu'il est
beaucoup plus dur le simple dur c'est
pas pareil ce n'est pas pareil
voilà nous leur posons vin je vais
prendre la poêle bon attendez je vais
vous sortir les mots résonnent après il
vient me jetez y sont jolies ils sont
superbes
ils sont magnifiques qui sont prêts ils
sont qui je crois que je peux les hauts
revenus
voilà ça va c'est très bien très bien
bien bien ils nous auront la place pour
faire les et voilà un roman construit
l'année fois au poivre vert voilà alors
on va laisser chauffer un tout petit peu
la toile aussi voilà mettre notre foi
s'en donne les bons ses fans ne diminue
pas là c'est pareil
alors toujours pareil à de gras dont
apple n'a pas le choix et c'est le foie
qui va lâcher voilà juste devant deux
jours sans jus voilà maintenant tout
doucement de sa crise aussi voilà le
voyait alors là ici nous allons mettre
le poulpe war vers voyais aussi du
poivre pas comme l'autre s'éduque war ar
mais il est vrai ils vont lever tout de
suite non attendez que ça fasse un tout
petit peu de jus au petit peu et dès
qu'il y aura un tout petit peu de jus on
va le mettre
mais ça commence voilà ici on va
réveiller
je suis pas plus la voilà
un des tout petits reste là
c'est là
et on va mettre le pouvoir rajouter un
petit peu de jus ça voilà il faut pas
voir dans les mains ça parce que le but
n'est pas très bon voilà voilà
que ces jolies maïté autres regardent
nos deux poêles là notamment par une
autre fois vers un tableau à 200
tableaux et ses délicieux on va les
retourner
voilà la sphère très peu de grand regret
vient aussi très très fun il va pas trop
vite la 9e fois nous avons envie ça me
voilà tu vas pas griller la gombe revers
là on nourrit envers y aura non non non
non c'est bien
non non non non comme il sera parfait de
regarder pour regarder la cuisson enfin
on peut le foie sans escale t il faut
pas qu'il soit rosé mais il faut pas
qu'il soit cinq ans les loyers d'arrêter
un corps sans sa pipe et les factures
trop cuit cet affreux un nom qu'on peut
pas rattraper maintenant on en a quatre
ascendant non non non non non non pas
trop cuit
l'enseignant être faire cuire tout
doucement voilà ça c'est la vraie
cuisine tout simple d'autrefois revoir
la seule difficulté en améliorant tiff
il faut être bon moment ce n'est pas
gourmand c'est fichu voilà bien
aujourd'hui nous sommes partis dès fois
ferait super comme celui là nous avons
commencé par faire les fois aux raisins
et au sauternes
alors on les avait fait mariner dans du
sauternes
avec un petit peu de porto on les a mis
à la sauteuse ont déjà fait dorer on a
ajouté nos grains de raisin qu'on avait
peu les épépiner cela musulmans enfin on
a vu la recette en pierre par ailleurs
nous avons fait des fois au poivre vert
ils sont bien bossé fois vrai et c'est
tout simple au fond c'est facile je
prévois est attentif faire attention à
la cuisson avoir de jolies fois et
finalement ils n'ont pas du tout grâce
au magnifique
aujourd'hui nous avons fait les fois aux
pommes qui sont ici la superbe aussi et
pour tous à une cuisson pour laquelle il
faut être très attentif
entre un quart d'heure vingt minutes et
comme nous l'alimenter un tout petit
coup de coude cotonou pour voir si c'est
juste à sandoz et par an dans des voiles
à l'intérieur là on a ce qu'on appelle
la cuisine royal voilà beaucoup de
simplicité la cuisine royal
[Musique]